cet homme est un barjot un barjot de
hand champion du monde en 1995
entraîneur depuis 97 pascal mahé est
arrivé à chartres la saison dernière
premier tir en haut à gauche la
diagonale en bas à droite
ok à chaque fois ces diagonales
quatrième du championnat de d2 les
euréliens veulent accéder à l'élite le
club s'appuie sur des joueurs
expérimentés des internationaux
étrangers deux d'entre eux étaient au
qatar pour les mondiaux l'accent est mis
aussi sur la formation et un pôle espoir
toujours efficace le fait qu'ils aient
une mixité comme ça entre jeunes et un
peu plus anciens de gens du cru comme
samuel faut qu'aucun un petit gamin de
la région et qui fait plaisir à voir
quand il est sur le terrain qui est
toujours très investi
voilà ça une résonance particulière pour
les gens d'ici et ça c'est ça aussi
important il a quand même toutes nos
amis la famille qui vient
au match et puis voilà je suis resté
quand même toujours dans cette salle
c'est un petit côté mythique et c'est
dans le coeur en fête que ce travail
lequel devrait battre encore plus fort
ce vendredi avec un gros match en coupe
l'adversaire des seizièmes de finale
n'est autre que dunkerque champion de
france évite même si la priorité reste
le championnat
c'est un match à jouer et savourer on
sait que le favori c'est dunkerque
maintenant tout ce qu'il ya à prendre
dans ce match on va le prendre on va
essayer de se régaler nous mêmes
après ça va être sympa parce que djoko
en coupe de france on a déjà joué des
premières divisions mais là c'est la
première fois qu'on reçoit la maison de
vente ouverte publiée que ça va être une
grande fête ça va être génial
les chartrains se prépare sérieusement
même s'il ya comme un brin d'esprit
barjots qui ressort je veux tu sais pas
moi